let's bring in our panel Fox News Chief
political analyst Brit Hume Kimberly
stel a member of the editorial board at
the Wall Street Journal and USA Today
White House correspondent Franchesca
Chambers Brett what do you make of this
extended ceasefire and this kind of you
know slow role of releasing of the
hostages in hamas's
control well it shows you why Hamas
picked up the hostages and took them in
the first place because they could deal
them like cards off a deck to buy time
for themselves I don't think this is at
all to Israel's military advantage in
fact I think quite the opposite but
there's a long custom tradition in
Israeli life that you do whatever you
have to do to redeem hostages you
remember the case of gilad Shalit Israel
traded a thousand uh Palestinian
prisoners to get one soldier back so
this is obviously compared to that this
is a better deal and we can't really
have good visibility Bread on how far
along the Israeli offensive is has gone
and how successful it has been but the
fact that Hamas has been willing to make
these deals and so urgently apparently
wants them suggests that they're you
know they're they're they're in trouble
they're having a hard time um so I you
know I think it's something Israel
probably would have preferred not to do
militarily felt it had to and maybe
it'll turn out that it it'll work out
for them after all kly understanding
that Israel is going to go forward
eventually once this pause uh stops to
try to go after Hamas leadership
there you can't rely on the numbers of
Civilian casualties but it is in the
thousands now inside Gaza
um what do we think about that and the
humanitarian efforts inside Gaza well
look I think that the israelies uh are
doing all that they can and this is one
of the other things that's remarkable is
the White House has obviously been very
much behind this truce in ceasefire uh
in Aid of getting the hostages out but
you also see progressives uh pushing for
a permanent ceasefire and now you have
Democrats in Congress calling to attach
conditions to any Israeli Aid that goes
forward saying that they want to see
more humanitarian conditions uh uh and
better adherence to Human Rights the
Israelis are doing everything that they
can um you know they've allowed for safe
corridors they've had pauses in bombings
they've warned everyone to get to the
south of Gaza uh in in order to not get
in the way of their operations to the
extent that we are seeing a of Civilian
casualties still it's because Hamas is
not letting people through uh they
continue to engage in operations
underneath or around civilian areas um
and I really think that responsibility
more of it needs to be put on those that
are putting those civilians in danger um
that cannot be uh the new argument for
why this ceasefire goes on forever um
even though you know that that is what
ham Hamas is going to continue to say
and those who are protesting the Israeli
operation yeah here's one of the family
members of talking about the hostage
deal take a
listen it's very bitter sweet I have
we've been through a nightmare absolute
nightmare of hell and the psychological
warfare at play is very much real you
know we have this high high of Danielle
and Amelia coming home on the other hand
this low of waiting for the rest of our
family yeah it's tough uh Franchesca the
politics of this at home uh it seems
like the Biden White house is taking a
little bit of criticism Washington Post
writes it this way White House grapples
with internal divisions on Israel Gaza
Biden's handling of what is arguably the
biggest foreign policy crisis of his
presidency is dividing a white house
that has prided itself on running a
disciplined and United operation the
Israel Gaza War has royed the
administration more than any other issue
in Biden's first three years in office
according to numerous AIDS and allies
inside and outside the White House as
staffers agonize over their positions on
highly emotional issues our latest poll
has a majority disapproving of the
president's handling of the Israel Hamas
War 39 to 55 are you feeling that
pressure over at the White House how
they deal with this Franchesca well
we've also seen it inside the state
department Brett where Secretary of
State Anthony blinkin issued a letter to
State Department staffers they've been
holding listening sessions as well at
the state department and as you talk
about polling more broadly an issue that
the president faces is that younger
Democrats in particular don't agree with
his handling of the war you mentioned a
political problem for him as you look
towards the 2024 election he needs young
voters in the Democratic party to turn
out for him and when they're disagreeing
with his foreign policy decisions here
also in broader polling as you pointed
out his foreign policy agenda hasn't
been particularly popular with Americans
they're facing a lot of difficulty on
these issues and you've heard the White
House house trying to take credit for
this uh temporary ceasefire in the
American who has been released and
potentially the release of the two other
additional women and it speaks to that
yeah one of the criticisms Brit is about
how uh they're handling Iran uh here's
the former house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy that's unacceptable but you
have to understand why do they feel
empowered to do this it wasn't something
that happened last week it's something
that happened when we changed
administrations under the Trump
Administration they were listed as
terrorist organizations they would know
they would not be in a position to do
this but in February
2021 Biden lifted it and they're no
longer listed as
terrorists and Britt we're now at more
than 70 attacks on US forces in the
Middle East it's not you know 10 20 it's
73 attacks on US military forces from
Iran proxies yeah and what and what
those comments from Kevin McCarthy
suggests is that this number that you're
seeing a disapproval number on the
president and this situation in the
Middle East uh a lot of it is people
think he isn't doing enough that he's
not strong enough against Iran that he
is soft in some respects in his support
for Israel I think by and large the
president's position on Israel versus
Hamas is is a position supported by a
huge majority of the American people so
why do you why one might ask is he
fighting this Mutiny inside his own his
own White House and inside his own
Administration and that I think Brett is
simple is simply this in governing he
came out not as the Centrist and the you
know the the center left dealmaker that
we thought we knew when he was in the
Senate and later as well U but as a guy
who governed from the left and there's a
price to be paid for doing that because
on the left is where their support for
Israel is weakest and his support for
Israel has got him in trouble it is part
of the price he is paying politically
for the way he is
governed Kimberly we're seeing Iran
proxies that haven't had a lot of power
uh seem like they have power even more
than they they have in the past you have
the hooti rebels supported by Iran New
York Times writing US Navy rescues ship
from Pirate attack in Gulf of Aiden the
United States investigating whether Iran
was involved in this incident directly
hours after the attack two missiles were
fired at the Navy ship involved in that
rescue the hooes have not been well well
armed but they're they're firing off
perhaps directly at us vessels yeah what
we're seeing is all of these groups
emboldened um and it's because they know
that there is this incredible reluctance
by the abiden administration to address
the root cause of Hamas Hezbollah the
huis which is Iran um there seems to be
this odd Desire by the administration
they continue to cling to this Iran
nuclear deal that was started obviously
under the Obama Administration Biden was
there there at the time they won't let
go of this and they're desperate almost
it seems to avoid any sort of greater
conflict with Iran and that has sent a
message to all of these groups that uh
this President isn't willing uh to take
steps and so why not continue to poke
the bear and and get more aggressive and
I think we're only going to see more of
that unless this Administration steps up
and faces the real problem which is the
the the the the group the organization
that Iran which is actually behind all
of the rest of this
yeah well panel thanks very much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else